ya está
[Aplausos]
lo hemos entendido lo hemos entendido no
hace falta explicarlo tantas veces ya
está pues nos salimos del círculo no
hace falta pues y no lo entendíamos
bien llevamos llevamos tres años
saltando nos la norma del punto rojo en
cada actuación nos hemos salido de él o
lo que sea
después de las presiones que hemos
recibido de la organización
no nos queda otra que dar un paso
adelante
un espectáculo más maduro
y si tenemos que anunciar los querido
público que de esta edición no nos vamos
a salir del círculo rojo
en este punto esperábamos de vuestra
parte 1
y ahora después de todo lo que os hemos
dado saliendo del círculo rojo
y sabéis y sabéis por qué porque no
vamos a salirnos del círculo rojo porque
sé por qué
porque no lo que salvará
realmente no vamos a entrar y no sólo
eso sin gracia además vamos a
asegurarnos que nadie más entra vamos a
asegurarnos porque este círculo hemos
visto que absorbe el conocimiento de los
ponentes durante 15 minutos y luego los
expulsa y eso no queremos mirar
exactamente eso va a pasar mira
van a cambiar muchas cosas aquí
ya que nos saltamos cada año
muy bien por qué no
muy bien organizado
un estado organizador mira vamos a hacer
una cosa a lo primero del círculo eso
tenemos que la hora que iba a poder
entrar y salir del círculo
el que quiera cuando quiera empezaron
las nuevas normas de interés
lo de no el máximo 18 minutos se acaba
el tiempo que queráis aquí podéis hablar
de lo que queráis de los más importantes
pero no hace falta
y el público en vez de callao os podréis
palomitas
[Música]
pero claro no es fácil montar una falta
porque hace falta público gente que
quiere venir a vernos hay verdades y eso
no es fácil el público que viene así es
muy fácil yo no tenemos hubiese gente
buena claro público del bueno del del
no creo que yo quiera
porque esto no es tan fácil claro no no
vais a tener que superar tres pruebas de
público pero ojo que os las vamos a
cronometrar tres pruebas de público y
aquí tener a sorpresa cuidado cuidado
estas tres mismas pruebas se están
haciendo en todos los eventos ted ex de
hoy que están teniendo lugar en el mundo
así que vamos a competir contra todos
ellos ojito estamos formamos parte de un
experimento global de coordinación
global muy bien pero vamos a ganar
vamos ahora no vamos a ganar vamos a
arrasar tien preparados
si queremos ganar si queremos arrasar
un grito de guerra me gusta el grito de
guerra es el siguiente grito de guerra
es haremos con tenemos nos traemos todos
queremos ganar si queremos ganar más
preparados 1 2 3 1
una cosa importante y vamos tenemos una
sorpresa preparada como he hecho antes
vélez en su interés la habana lo único
bueno por motivos técnicos al final no
ha sido posible y queremos hacer un
streaming para poder competir
con ellos porque en tiempos estamos en
el mismo momento ellos ya han acabado al
final no ha sido posible sabemos los
tiempos que han hecho
pero no vamos a decir van a condicionar
y lo que sigue al menos después del
esfuerzo sí que tenemos una conexión
desde la banda de charly nos escucha a
charly tenemos a nuestro charlie nos
escucha como la cosa de locos
palencia valencia
para la música
por la charla oye compadre [ __ ] qué
alegría me cante la amarró y aquí la
gente está que se ha salido hoy el set
habana con el espíritu del 500
aniversario de esta ciudad tan linda tan
bella a la que os invitamos a que vengan
y bueno la gente se ha volcado la gente
se preparó la gente el concurso fue
tremendo esto fue tremenda gozadera que
lo sepas y bueno hoy el arte de bailar
[Música]
vale
lo mejor es que vamos a nosotros
un abrazo charla dimensión está está
jodida que vamos a hacer quería
aprovechar para enviarle un saludo de la
habana caluroso a 35 grados con sabor a
caribe
que los tenemos en el corazón les
felicitamos por el quinto aniversario y
que sea muchísimo más
ésta no podemos matar
[Aplausos]
la primera prueba vamos con la primera
prueba del grito de guerra
muy bien muy natural bueno vamos ahora
sí con la primera prueba
atención porque estos momentos estamos
repartiendo cuatro letras que estarán en
las cuatro esquinas
[Música]
[Aplausos]
atención porque vamos a tener que
atención porque el reto va a ser que
daremos salida una dos y tres y
tendremos que pasar las letras de
persona en persona no vale lanzar la
nueva ley saltarse lo tendremos que ir
pasando y las letras tendrán que ir por
todo el patio de butacas así haciendo
eses así así así así hasta llegar al
centro y allí lo mismo saldrán así muy
bien estamos muy bien muy bien tenemos
ahí las cheerleaders y saldrán saldrán
así haciendo es ésta está tratada hasta
llegar al centro y formaremos la palabra
télex cuando esté formada pararemos el
tiempo si tenemos que ganar tenemos
también vamos a ganar que hay que
pasarla bien vosotros la pasa es como
podáis buenamente dando bien malditos
señales preparados y 321
mal
e
[Música]
vamos
ahí
ahora tenemos una vuelta verdad
tenemos falta de la palabra
ahora mi verdad
tiempo al tiempo para tiempo muy bien
hemos conseguido poner áreas donde los
mosquitos lo de los mosquitos muy bien
bebés
gracias a ver es que lo de ordenar la de
atrás eso era muy complicado verdad nos
habían dicho esta gente que tiene
suministros ha dicho el mejor público
bueno bien
atención porque nuestro tiempo son 44
segundos
[Música]
no está más de la prueba superada su
atención el tiempo es
y quiénes son los organizada segunda más
complicada todavía tenéis que poneros de
acuerdo así a vuestro rollo
nosotros no vamos a decir nada y cantar
la misma canción
todos lo que quiero es hacer lo que
queráis pero un año normal hará cuando
consigamos cantar todos la misma canción
y más normas preparadores 21 tiempo
cuando queráis
[Aplausos]
y
dios me ama
[Aplausos]
como los que me habéis hablaba antes
antes de entrar todos no los de la
tercera y última prueba atención porque
llega la tercera y última prueba tenemos
todos un folio rojo que iba a nuestro
kit abre es el momento de sacar lo
tendréis cuando contemos tres tendréis
que hacer el mejor avión que podáis el
primer momento cuando digamos tres el
más grave que podáis y levantarlos sin
lanzarlo lo levantaremos sin hacerlo y
cuando nosotros contemos 321 lo
lanzaremos ya irse para el tiempo
preparados para construir tenéis todos
el folio sostenemos el folio de manera
perfecta el mejor avión que podáis
construir a ver esos ingenieros
sí
321 tiempo
rápido aire aire aire
pero no solo levantamos solo levantamos
solo levantamos y aún faltan algunas por
ahí
muy bien esa voluntario es muy bien
sin faltar algunos en el sector
vamos vamos para atención sí
es nuestro mejor bueno es todo uno
[Aplausos]
pero ni todo fuera muy bien
atención esto es importante y no me
diréis nuestro tiempo
un detalle un detalle si lo más lento
será hacer el avioncito ha sido los más
listos de nuestro tiempo como fedex en
valencia
mañana saldrán los resultados en las
redes de todos los tratamientos de todos
ustedes del mundo es de 138
[Música]
1 2 3 1
bien cada vez más natural así que con
cara de feos así como sociedad cuando se
nos lanza un reto tenemos una
de poder coordinarnos de
pero también tenemos la capacidad
de poder hacerlo
en cualquier dirección
al abrigo de cualquier idea
cambiarlas sin demasiado esfuerzo e
incluso llevarla al polo opuesto a veces
funcionamos como una veleta emocional de
ideas sobre era que se convierte en
contenidos informaciones se nos dan unas
informaciones y las contrarias y al
final acabamos perdiendo nuestro
criterio propio
y nos dejamos arrastrar
de las masas que actúan más desde
las emociones que descripción obviamente
esto las empresas de comunicación lo
controlan lo dominan y con ello nos
venden productos sensaciones miedos e
ideologías una idea sencilla expuesta
con claridad con contundencia presentada
por líderes de opinión
convencidos
una idea envuelta en una
a externa una amenaza además cuanto más
difusa
cuanto más lejana mejor funciona
inseguridad
ataque contra nuestras costumbres y
nuestras nuestras religiones una idea
así es capaz de ponernos de unirnos a
todos contra
en un tiempo récord
qué hubiera pasado si nos hubiéramos
dicho que competíamos contra
esas amenazas externas que querían el
mismo objetivo que nosotros ser los
primeros
hubiéramos actuado con la misma eficacia
motivación fuerza coordinación
si en vez de decir que competíamos
contra otras text hubiéramos dicho que
participamos con otras t de c's por un
bien común
y esta era la idea que hoy nos gustaba
queríamos compartir somos muy capaces de
unirnos contra algo
pero somos menos capaces o nos cuesta
más unirnos por
porque para unirnos contra algo no hace
falta mucho discurso solo hace falta
levantar mucho la voz tener los dos
líderes que alcen además sin demasiado
contraste como habéis visto
y sobre todo sobre todo para unirnos
contra algo es muy fácil final solo hace
falta tener unos símbolos comunes unas
canciones comunes unos unos saludos
comunes pero para unirnos
para pensar en el bien común para pensar
no a corto plazo sino para pensar a
medio ya largo plazo para eso
a mucha sensibilidad
un poquito de humor
cómo les ha ido en esta experiencia te
des la habana con los que competíamos en
directo si vamos a contactar con ellos a
ver cómo ha ido este experimento global
y nos da miedo charlie y explicar este
experimento político
hay un poco de retorno sé que está muy
lejos hoy viene a mis manos como pasó la
cosa y me cuenta nosotros por encima es
la gente que cantó aquí cantar un
merengue allí que cantaron sí que
cantaron feliz
se me subió la bilirrubina
y luego hablamos como la gente porque
aquí tenemos mucha imaginación
gracias charlie sheen hoy antes de
echarle ya que si cortamos la
comunicación le quería decir que vélez
en el equipo rectoral
chau ahora la fiesta hasta que es hasta
que se seque el malecón
chau
[Aplausos]
a quien le hemos llamado toda la gente
que había más llamaré es tiempo de
educación es tiempo de cultura es tiempo
de feminismo es tiempo de experiencia es
tiempo de ciencia es tiempo de
conciencia es tiempo de télex es tiempo
de todos esos espacios que nos pueden
ayudar a actuar con mayor criterio
equilibrio y generosidad es tiempo de
unirnos por todos esos grandes desafíos
que nos esperan en este siglo 21 es
tiempo de unirnos por todas esas ideas
que nos han presentado nuestros
compañeros oradores
[Aplausos]
[Música]